um this being an LP talk let me start
with some poetry we have also obtained a
glimpse of another crucial idea about
languages and program design this is the
thing which I greatly feared is come
upon us desolation and destruction if
that particular passage doesn't make any
sense to you that's okay it was
generated by a language model a Markov
chain in this case that was trained on
the Bible and and the programming book
called the structure and interpretation
of computer programs yes there's more of
that at that address if you're
interested in seeing what comes there's
lots of interesting quotes there but of
course so that that language model isn't
really meant to do anything particularly
useful it's mainly for fun possibly for
learning for the author who is not me
but this idea of language models has
fairly recently in the last sort of 12
or so months gained quite a lot of
Attraction in the NLP community because
the the what's what's been dubbed sort
of the image net moment of NLP we've
realised the NLP community to realize
that we can actually use the language
models as a basis for training all kinds
of other models for all kinds of other
tasks in NLP that has led to somewhat
concerning headlines this particular one
is related to the non release of a
language model from open AI a private
Research Institute where the researcher
the researchers there were specifically
concerned that the model is good enough
in generating text that a bad actor
could use that model to generate sort of
posts and text in online forums and sort
of replicate or
create a community around some concept
or some idea where one where that
community doesn't actually exist think
of I don't know fake news for political
purposes for instance okay so what's
going on here I'll try to in the next I
don't know eighteen seventeen minutes
kind of go over what's been happening in
the research field in NLP over the last
roughly twelve months
and specifically give you an intuition
as to what the what the these language
models are and then look at how we are
deploying those into production how
we're taking these research efforts and
putting them into production at at come
travel where I work as a research
engineer so what's been happening in
research this is a snapshot of research
results for machine translation this
particular one is for English to French
and you can see a kind of an optic there
around sort of beginning of last year
ish similar this is English to German
not quite the same sort of optic but
still the curves are going up which is
nice this is question answering there's
a very very significant improvement
suddenly in like within the space of
this is July 18 to about now so that's
less than twelve months and we've added
about thirty percent to the to the
performance and then finally language
modeling itself this GPT to model that
you see here this is the specific model
that the open AI researchers decided not
to release because of because of its
capability of producing convincing
language okay so what our language
models so if I were to say that they're
kind of models that are in very very
general terms just trying to predict the
next element in a sequence is being
language and they're being language
models that sequence
words and the next element in that
sequence is the next word so if I'm
gonna say okay you can't guess what I'm
about to say then you might reasonably
claim that the following word is going
to be next with possibly a chance of 12%
I'm unlikely to say Apple following that
sentence this is kind of the very
general idea about language models so
why is this useful as a way of kind of
capturing language and using this
learning process as a basis for other
kinds of NLP tasks why would this help
me to document classification well if we
if we look at a little bit more
complicated oral but somewhat more
different sentence the train up to
Hamburg today was really slow but I had
time to enjoy the scenery versus but he
was also uncomfortable now the second
sentence there the read sentence there
seems somehow wrong because the
conjunction bot is supposed to introduce
some kind of a contradiction in terms
so it's supposed to reverse somehow the
sentiment of whatever the first part of
the clause is but the two parts in the
read sentence have actually the same
sentiment and the same if you are
inclined to speak German
the dog is a good example for this in
German its door is supposed to kind of
negate whatever some other person just
said to me and I go like no no no so in
order for the language model to learn to
predict what the next word after bot is
or the next words after that is it has
to not just be able to memorize some
sequence of words but it has to actually
learn something about the grammatical
role that the words play in the sentence
and how those impact the semantics and
so on and so on how do these models
actually work and how are they then
deployed into production or like
deployed into other tasks so this is a
picture from a paper called universal
language model of fine tuning
the two columns on the Left
depict the sort of language model itself
so you have a neural network of some
depth in this case they have the three
middle layers are a recurrent neural
network they're just three identical
recurrent neural networks stacked on top
of each other and you first you train
that that takes a very very long time
but the idea is that within those
weights within that stack of recurrent
neural networks you've internalized
something about the language that that
you happen to be looking at and then in
the final column on the on the left yes
sorry on your right my left they change
you you change what the model is
supposed to be doing so you take out
that last layer but you keep everything
else you keep all of the knowledge that
the language or the model has learned
about language and then you swap out the
last layer and say well now you're not
predicting the next word anymore now you
need to predict the class of a document
is this positive sentiment or negative
sentiment is this a booking or is it not
a booking for instance this is one way
of doing is there's another way of doing
that which is to say that the that we
don't keep we use the language model as
just a feature extractor so this is a
paper from solando research and what
they do is the the character language
model that you see there on the bottom
that is used as a feature extractor to
create word embeddings and then document
embeddings which are then fed into just
a regular sequence model but the
language model once you transfer that
once you've trained the language model
it's sort of not part of your prediction
tasks anymore you're just using it to
get some kind of a representation of the
data that you have which you then feed
to a separate classifier predictor
something there's a really really good
blog post by the way the bottom link
there by Lillian Wang
she goes through all of these different
sort of ideas and different
implementations and and there's links to
all of the different papers I don't have
all the papers here but that blog post
it's a long read but it's worth worth
looking at so okay so how does this
translate into production then let's
start with what comp travel isn't what
we're actually trying to do so con
travel is a business travel agency we
get bookings via email from our
customers and we want to do an
end-to-end automation pipeline where
upon received of an email we run that
email through the pipeline and and we
get an offer which we then return or
send back to the to the customer usually
hopefully within a couple of minutes so
in this case where the customer is
requesting a hotel for a famous famous
famous Finnish footballer for mid-may
now of course this is not quite as
simple as just sending out the offer so
my work focuses mostly on this NLP part
here and the NLP is feeding data and we
need to talk to a lot of external API is
in blah blah blah blah blah so what the
NLP is supposed to do is extract the
relevant bits of information from from
the email and formalize that into some
kind of a request that we can then feed
into the search engine formalize request
might look something like this so we've
nailed down that it's a hotel booking we
know where it is we know which hotel you
want we know what your when you want to
go there how many rooms you want do you
want Wi-Fi do you want parking breakfast
not breakfast and so on not all of this
information is necessarily always in the
messages that we get not all of this
information is necessarily always
required if you don't tell us when you
would like to book the hotel it's going
to be difficult for us to do so
but I mean we don't necessarily need to
know if you want Wi-Fi or not the same
obviously applies for flights the
destination of flight is relatively
important whereas I don't know your
frequent flyer number
it's a shame if we miss it but it's not
it's not the most relevant piece of
information and then of course there's
always the messages there's always the
possibility that the messages contain
more than just a single booking request
in the in the request above the idea was
that you get either this whole their
hotel or that hotel so we need to be
able to represent combinations of
requests per message so how does then
the research translate into this task
that we need to do this information
extraction task so let's try to put a
little bit more meat on this so this is
now a different request but this is what
a machine translation task could for
instance look like so you need a morning
flight from Berlin to Helsinki early on
the 10th or an afternoon evening flight
after 6:00 p.m. and then you'd also like
a hotel and you want to fly it back on
the 12th we can try to formalize that as
a sequence to sequence prediction tasks
so the machine translation models
usually try to consume some kind of an
input sequence which in this case is our
message create a representation of that
some kind of an embedding within a
neural network and then from that
embedding not from the original sequence
but from that embedding from that
representation produce some output
sequence and in this case our output
sequence would just be the kind of
formalized slots along with the relevant
bits of the text that go into those
slots there's a somewhat obvious problem
here which is that we don't actually
care what the order of this of the
predict of the outputs
I don't care if the model outputs the
departure of the flight before the
origin of the flight or the departure
time before the origin or if the
destination comes before or after the
origin because they are formalized I can
tell from the output how to then process
that further and feed that into whatever
system I need to feed it into but that's
a that's a sort of a bad feed because
the the sequence the sequence models are
optimized in such a way that they are
sensitive to the order of the output
sequence whereas in our case the we're
not really I mean partially we are but
not really so we would need to somehow
at least change the the lost function so
that it becomes not any more sensitive
to the to the sequence no to the to the
order of the output sequence but then
it's questionable whether we should be
using that model in the first place or
not here's another option question
answering the dynamic memory networks
paper the aim there was to try to create
a generic architecture that is
applicable to a number of different NOP
tasks their claim is that that most if
not all NOP tasks can be translated into
a question/answer format this is kind of
where my idea of well let's just
entertain what if what would it look
like if we take our tasks and and then
try to translate those into some other
something that's somewhat known into it
so again the same request we now have a
set of assertions fly from Berlin to
Helsinki fly early in the morning and so
on and then a bunch of questions and
answers to those again the problem here
is that it's not it's not entirely clear
to me how to translate that original
text into that set of assertions or at
least that would be another prediction
problem
that I need to solve before I can solve
this problem possibly we could actually
just feed the original text as it is to
the model if you have any experience
with these I would love to talk to you
and then finally this is kind of the
very very traditional NLP approach so we
have an input sequence and we have an
output sequence that is exactly the same
length so for every token you produce an
output token this is for instance what
named entity recognition does but in our
case the like we're not outputting named
entities were outputting these labels
for well this is the origin of the fly
this is the destination this is the
departure time blah blah blah blah blah
and then there's a bunch of tokens in
there there's a bunch of words in our
input that are completely meaningless so
we just label them as oh the problem
here is that the way in which we need to
combine because if you look at morning
and early on the tenth those are
actually those go into the same slot but
they're separated in the in the input
and the output sequence so we need to
put in we need to add lots of logic on
top of this before we can actually say
that are the the departure is early on
the 10th in the morning not for instance
early in the afternoon of the 10th which
would also be a possibility
this is incidentally what we are
actually using okay so a few
considerations that we need to pay
attention to when we're looking at some
research and entertaining whether we
should even look at it how well does the
model fit to what we need to do another
way to think about this is the like how
convoluted do we need to make the
evaluation before we can get something
meaningful out of it think of the
question answering tasks that we're in
order for us to use that kind of an
approach we would actually need to have
a possibly a secondary task that we
solve before we can solve the actual
terms that's a very convoluted way of
thinking about this how well can we
identify isolate and fix errors any
model that we do produce is going to
have some errors and we need to be able
to well identify isolate and fix them
ideally so if we have one huge model
that solves the entire problem in one go
any change that we make to that model is
very likely to introduce some
regressions somewhere else
that we didn't intend so thus far we've
kind of gone with with trying to pick
apart the models and and rather apply a
sequence of models then then try to
encapsulate everything into one single
model the problem with that is that the
errors between the models tend to
multiply so if we make an error very
very early in the pipeline then
everything else is somewhat meaningless
there's of course deployment costs we
need to be aware of what the memory
requirements are we need to be aware of
like do we need specialized hardware and
then is there a reliable implementation
available a lot of research nowadays in
NLP tends to have some implementations
available some of them are quite wonky
and you really don't want to use them
some
them are not maybe there's others that I
forgot to mention this is what then sort
of looking at what we currently have in
production so we have kind of two main
tasks or two main levels of looking at
this problem document or document level
classification we have three classifiers
there there's a booking classifier does
this message contain a booking or does
it not contain a booking is it I don't
know is the customer just wanting to
change their address or a frequent flyer
number or is it a cancellation or do
they actually want to book a trip what
is the content of that booking is it a
flight is the hotel is a combination and
then is it finally is it in scope we're
not even trying to handle bookings that
contain you know 15 different flights
and two trains for 17 different people
that's if we see something like that
that's just passed on to the human
travel agents immediately the model that
we're using is the model from the bag of
tricks for efficient text classification
there's the kind of a cartoonish version
of what it looks like but that's
actually the model this is super simple
it's very easy to to implement it it has
relatively low memory requirements it's
very quick to Train this is any works
really well we've been looking at lots
and lots of way more complicated models
with language models and all kinds of
stuff we've been completely unable to
find anything that there's lots of
things that match the performance of
that in terms of just raw metrics but
they also take a week to train so thus
far we've just been sticking with that
then the information instruction or the
slot filling task we currently have a
really weird model that was empowered
inspired by some keggle competitions in
the past don't pay any attention to that
I've made it extra small so that so you
can't read it
it's a convolutional neural network this
does feature extraction and then like a
recurrent neural network on top of that
which makes absolutely no sense to me
that's gonna go away we have this the
model from the from the researchers at
solando we have already tested that I'm
currently training a full sort of
production version of that model we know
that we get a lot lot better performance
out of it so this is absolute
improvement of about 13 percentage
points in f1 averaged over 71 labels
that's of at least for us that's a very
very significant improvement in
performance the only downside is that it
takes a week to train it on a GPU
machine and then we need a GPU machine
to deploy it and so on but you know it
does much much better there's a bunch of
models or there's a bunch of problems
that we haven't been able to find
anything in the research field for one
of the main ones is time expressions
these tend to be extremely difficult to
find and interpret correctly so we were
using a solution from Facebook before
but then we built our own which is
called CT parse that's an open source
library if you want to look at it you
can find it on github it works very well
for us but it is targeted for our use
case so if you want to use it for
something minimum requirement is that
all of your time expressions with point
to the future we do not handle the past
no one wants to book a hotel for last
week there's a bunch of ongoing research
that we're looking into a lot of it is
for the document level classification
we're just sort of trying to tie up some
loose ends and figure out if we can't
find anything better than than the fast
text or the
bag of tricks time parsing as I said
there's a bunch of stuff that I'm
looking into in terms of T the sequence
prediction the the slot filling task
mainly there as well as or the top thing
there is side coupling with pre-trained
language models the model from Salander
research is going to go into production
but there's a whole bunch of other stuff
that we still need to look into and make
sure that that does better and yeah time
parsing recommendation is one we are
hiring if you have any interest in NLP
and recommendation systems and really
complicated datasets come talk to me
here's some pitfalls to avoid start with
really really simple models don't don't
take the latest research just take
something that you know is going to work
and establish a baseline if you don't
have a baseline with a really simple
model that you can run on your laptop
you have absolutely no idea how anything
stacks you you don't know what you
should do
state of the art is often it's the way a
cat the academia works is often very
misleading just getting half a
percentage point of an improvement on
the state of the art is often completely
useless for production we don't care
because there's so many different other
considerations that we need to take into
account that that half a percentage
point on some specific task on some
specific data set all of that goes out
the window once once we incorporate
everything else into it one part of that
everything else is that because we're
trying to create this booking if we get
one single slot wrong on a request the
rest of the Requa
doesn't matter if we don't understand
what the destination of the flight is it
doesn't matter if we get the departure
time correctly and this is where the
this is where the the academic
evaluation measures are often very
misleading for us because it they don't
take these sort of I don't know like
hierarchical evaluation measures often
into account they're focused on the
document level or the token level but we
need to kind of pay attention to both at
the same time once you have a baseline
don't don't be afraid to have just
completely crazy ideas it if even if it
doesn't work it's going to further your
understanding of why it doesn't work
what the data looks like and it at least
it's fun to think about some other
things while your model is training
here's some recommended reading I would
actually even recommend that you read it
in this specific order the NLP is
imagenet moment by service T and roller
that's a really really good overview of
this whole idea of training these
language models then generalized time
which models by Lillian Wang is much
much more in-depth view of like how
specifically do these models work each
and every single one of them and then
finally once you've gotten yourself
really excited about how everything's
gonna be great in the future please go
and read NLP is generalization problem
and then sort of come back down to earth
I apologize for being over time for
those who have been thank you for
listening the work isn't done alone
that's the rest of the team we are a
very fairly small bunch at least for the
time being